we're following breaking news out of
North Korea three American prisoners
there have been released and they are on
their way home now Kim dong-chul Kim
Hawk song and Tony Kim are expected to
arrive at Joint Base Andrews near
Washington at 11 p.m. Pacific time
President Trump says he will be there to
greet them the plane carrying the
prisoners and Secretary of State Mike
Pompeo landed in Japan a short time ago
the president announced their release on
Twitter saying all three men appear to
be in good health
Ben Tracy is following developments from
Beijing Ben good morning good morning so
secretary Pompeo met with kim jeong-hoon
for 90 minutes and were told that it was
after that meeting that he was informed
that these three Americans were going to
be released now these three men had been
accused of unspecified hostile acts by
the North Koreans and less than an hour
after they were granted amnesty the
three Americans were on the Secretary's
plane and headed towards Japan now
according to the White House the men
appear to be in good health they were
able to walk on the plane without
assistance
now the Trump administration has been
saying for weeks now that it would be a
gesture of goodwill by the North Koreans
if they were to release these Americans
before the summit this was Secretary of
State Pompeo second visit to North Korea
in the past two months and he met with
Kim jong-un both times now this morning
President Trump tweeted that Pompeo had
a good meeting with Kim jong-eun and
that a date in place for the upcoming
summit has been set now the family of
Tony Kim one of the Americans who has
just been released they put out a
statement thanking president Trump for
engaging directly with North Korea and
helping bring him home Gayle and Tracy
from Beijing thank you this is very good
news but I keep thinking about the warm
beers today we're very happy for that
family but I keep thinking about them
too I know the family oh boy this is one
step in terms of right before that
meeting the North Koreans showing some
goodwill ahead of that meeting that is
now set to take place and also for a
chaotic Trump presidency this has been a
methodical series of steps on the way to
this meeting so far in terms of laying
this out led by the Secretary of State
certainly more to come